the album post tramatic is 16 songs and
it's about it's kind of a diary yeah and
it tracks you know starting from a place
where you know I lost my friend my
collaborator and how down that was and
how complicated really complicated it
was and tried to capture all the
complexities of what that was and then
how at a certain point I started
naturally looking towards the future and
looking towards more hopeful things yeah
when you were in the process of putting
all that music together we any point
becoming self-aware in terms of like
what the album would be to other people
like what it would mean to those
listening to it as you were creating it
yeah like I was in the beginning I was
just making stuff just to kind of it was
a meditative kind of thing I was just
making it to make it and it made me feel
more like centered sure to just do it
it's almost like doodling on the phone
and you're like on the phone and just
kind of like yeah yeah like it felt like
that or it feels like that when I do it
mm-hmm
but also there was it became also very
analytical but self-aware like okay I
have this opportunity to like dig into
these things that I'm feeling and
experiencing that are unique they're not
they're not like you know somebody else
who has these situations so what is that
about and I put those into the record
and I and it was this weird collection
of all those things as as it went along
mm-hmm I think that you know with your
career with Linkin Park the music that
you guys made it connected with fans in
a lot of ways and in a lot of ways also
help people recognize their emotions
struggles they are going through and
helping them kind of get through it to
to the other end maybe in a way is this
also a version of that for you like when
you think about the people that will be
listening to it do you think maybe this
will also help them process grief yeah I
see I see what you're saying so it's
yeah as I was making stuff I definitely
was I was watching social media of
course at home always we're all always
and there were there were moments when I
realized that number one the fans were
so sweet and encouraging to me that they
were actually helping me along yeah I
was being affected by like things that
I'd read and things they would say so I
started at first I wasn't responding to
anything cuz I just felt weird yeah and
once I started doing it it just felt
great to like acknowledge people and say
like I I read your thing it was really
nice it made me feel good and to give
little positive messages here and there
and when I did that the kinds of
responses and then sheer number of
responses when I would do that it was
making people know like I'm still here
mm-hmm
I'm doing good today like today is a
nice time feel I feel good cool so yeah
as as I did apply that to like my
outlook on the record yeah on the songs
I was making at one point and realized
that I have an opportunity not only to
connect with people and say like this is
something I felt and I you probably have
felt the same way at some point maybe if
I'm really lucky I can say something in
a way that they wanted to say that they
haven't been able to that's always like
a homerun for me yeah and then to just
be able to get up on stage and play some
of the songs and and I feel like that's
a place where it brings it home like it
it's it's shows for me always are
supposed to feel even these shows even
in the context of everything that's
happened I want the shows to feel fun I
want them to be something you're looking
forward to that while it does have an
element of won't be in a couple places
in the set there's like a tribute moment
we play I play in the end and the crowd
sings Chester's parts like that's a
beautiful moment every night but of when
I play like my solo stuff when I play
for minor stuff and when I play some of
some other Linkin Park stuff it's just
it's fun to sing it it's nice to let a
lot of that stuff out and there's just a
little more gravity yeah which is it in
a good way like it feels like bigger
than a show
I think it's cool that idea that you
were able to connect with fans during
the process of
actually creating this like like sort of
day-to-day check-in with them and then
checking in with you having that maybe
inform what you're doing in the album
you you touch on this theme of like your
own reaction to the reactions that
people have when they're you know when
they're when they're maybe trying to
console you or or or just like show that
they care yeah
and there's some anger and some pushback
can you elaborate on when what those
emotions are like well one thing that we
that I I think I responded to somebody
at some point because they on on like
Twitter or something so he kind of
criticized me for something that I said
about anger and it was just one person
it was just like one comment that I was
like you know what like this is a t just
like as they would say at my kids school
this is a teachable moment mm-hmm and I
don't say that with any I'm not it's not
a condescending thing it's like it is a
moment where we have open an opening for
like a conversation about the fact that
when you go through something difficult
the they talk about stages of grief one
of them is anger and anger is natural
it's not something you should be I mean
I don't want to just freely allow myself
to just lash out at people that's
obviously inappropriate but to feel
anger that's not something that I have
control over like you actually it will
feel angry about things you'll snap over
weird stuff just because you're coping
mm-hmm with something heavy so that's
kind of what we talked about what we had
a little back-and-forth and them and
them on social media about that and I
realized that there are a lot of other
people that jumped in right away and
said thank you for saying that right
because you know people don't understand
me my family doesn't understand me and
my friends don't understand because I'm
going through this thing yeah and it
helps me explain it and backing way out
looking the big picture just talking
about these things it's so healthy it's
so useful it's like in the context of
all of this stuff whether it's Chester
or Chris Cornell or Kate Kate Spade or
Anthony Bourdain we've with mental
health there's we talk about our
physical health like this week we get up
we have you know aches and pains
we might say oh that's bad I feel I feel
my back hurt I feel like I should take
it easy today maybe it's worse and we
say I need to take medication maybe it's
worse and we say oh I need to see a
doctor too
mental health is health we we've got to
take that same approach and say oh I'm
aware of my my brain right now I'm aware
of my emotions right now
I'm not feeling so good I need to take
it easy oh I'm feeling worse than that I
need to take medication oh I'm feeling
worse than that any see a professional
and those are all totally ok things to
do and normal and it doesn't matter
whether you're you know you're just a
kid in your parents house or you're you
know me you've got of address that stuff
and you just it's healthy to talk about
it and the more you talk about it the
more manageable it actually yeah yeah
now you're an artist that works in all
sorts of media but you said before that
like the packaging of your albums is
important because you're a visual guy to
you like you're making music you're
rapping so you yourself I think you you
probably have a good handle of who you
are as an artist but when you think
about fans or people from the outside
looking at you in a relationship to like
them being fans of Linkin Park and you
know certainly in the aftermath of
Chester's passing and you now moving
forward as a solo artist like how do you
feel about yourself moving forward what
were the kind of pressures that you feel
they're different than you felt before
what kind of the freedoms that you might
have now that you didn't have that well
the the the first thing I would say the
first part is like this isn't the path
that I would have chosen right it's just
this is the cards that I've been dealt
and I'm gonna I'm gonna do my best and
so when I'm doing it I was thinking at
one point about that you know this this
body of work that I made these paintings
I made I made 10 a series of 10
paintings actually as I was making the
song and they became the album packaging
so it's all the stuff that I created and
I it's so personal yeah that I realized
ok can't be Linkin Park and it shouldn't
really be my other side project Fort
Minor and it needs to feel new so
that's why I used my name I just went it
did it as a approached it as a solo
project because it's personal the other
thing it does is when you're in a group
at least from my experience our our band
has always been a democracy yeah and so
doing things in a group you you you know
I want to make sure that everybody's
happy if we've got a song and you know
what of the six members if one guy
didn't like it we would always address
that okay what would what didn't you
like and we changed the thing and work
hard on it until they were happy too and
then all six of us liked it but that
takes a lot of extra work and it puts a
lot of the like it complicates things
makes things a little slower complicated
and right now just for my own health
what I need is a little more control
over it and a little more like singular
voice and spontaneity right so this
whole thing that I'm doing right now it
feels to me it's very spontaneous like
the show the other night I added like
two songs to the set I made like I had
like a 60-minute set planned I was on
stage for like 85 minutes
yeah just adding stuff and screwing
around and talking to the crowd and all
this and that feels great to me yeah how
do you feel like this is changing you as
a performer and and even you know
listening to your own music changing you
as a person I don't know yet yeah what I
mean the album itself is like the
beginning of a it's like a part of the
journey or it's the beginning of the
journey and whereas with what I've
experienced for so many years kind of
the expectation my expectation has been
like you put out an album and you tour
it for a period of time and then you
rest and then you do it again and it all
fits into the context of like the legacy
or the the thing that is Linkin Park
yeah right now it's almost like a
Aboriginal like walkabout like I just
feel like I'm out in the world checking
stuff out yeah seeing where it goes yeah
and I don't know what'll happen and
that's kind of like refreshing for me
and fun yeah if I decide like if I
decide right now to start filming this
whole thing with with my phone
I want to make that the next like music
video I want to make a song about this
like heeey that's something I realize
now like I can just do that I know I
mean I guess I can't do that because et
Canada would probably say hey that's our
logo no but in all seriousness there is
a spontaneity and a do-it-yourself kind
of nature to this which is super fun for
me and it feels very it feels healthy it
feels like what I ought to be doing
you